la france est elle soumise à l'union
européenne pas une seule décision n'est
prise sans en aviser bruxelles ce qui
n'est plus le cas du royaume-uni qui a
rompu ses relations avec l'ue eux
alors face au co by 2,19 londres a pris
de l'avancé a même chipé au nez et à la
barbe de paris un vaccin français le
gouvernement a pleinement soutenu ce
vaccin prometteur contre le coc u19 en
finançant les premiers essais cliniques
je suis ravi de constater que plus de
4000 participants ont été recrutés
rapidement ceux qui démontent
l'excellent travail de nos équipes de
recherche et le dévouement du pays pour
vaincre ce virus le déploiement
impressionnant de ce vaccin a montré la
force de notre union
ce vaccin c'est celui de val neva un
laboratoire de saint-herblain près de
nantes
son vaccin est déjà en études cliniques
de phase iii et le présente un avantage
non négligeable il peut se conserver
dans un simple réfrigérateur
contrairement aux autorités britanniques
américaines et allemandes qui avaient
aidé à pfizer et biotech à mettre au
point le vaccin le plus diffusé dans le
monde aujourd'hui
le gouvernement français n'a pas tendu
la main aux petits poucets pour l'aider
à finaliser ces travaux commencés en
avril 2020 et les discussions entamées
avec l'union européenne ont rapidement
fait pschitt
lorsque des entreprises souhaitent que
leur vaccin soit intégré à notre
portefeuille de vaccins
un certain ensemble de conditions doit
être respectée comme une protection
solide dans les domaines de la sécurité
de la responsabilité civile une
efficacité du vaccin mais aussi des
règles et des dispositions solide ou
encore la livraison des vaccins
une aubaine pour le royaume uni qui ne
s'est pas fait prier non seulement le
pays a permis l'organisation rapide des
essais cliniques et les a financés mais
il a aussi ouvert une usine de
production sur son propre territoire
190 millions de doses ont d'ores et déjà
été pré commandé par londres ce vaccin
sera fabriquée sur place à livingstone
en écosse donnant ainsi un nouvel élan
aux sciences de la vie britannique
et s'il est approuvé il joue un rôle
important dans la protection de nos
communautés pour ne pas être en retard
nous sommes allés au premier
gouvernement qui nous a aidés il est
logique que contractuellement on se soit
engagé à livrer le royaume uni en
premier sans ce contrat nous n'aurions
sans doute pas pu mener nos recherches à
leur terme
une priorité britannique qui suscite la
colère de plusieurs élus et de citoyens
envers le gouvernement français
à commencer par la présidente de la
région pays de la loire
c'est un véritable gâchis de voir les
vaccins valnet va partir au royaume uni
les britanniques ont déroulé le tapis
rouge à cette pépite ce que la france
n'a pas fait on marche sur la tête
il est temps de faire preuve de plus de
réactivité de flexibilité et de
simplification il existe un vaccin
français en stade expérimental 3 celui
de val neva mais curieusement ce sont
nos voisins britanniques qui en sont les
acheteurs et promoteurs en pleine
quatrième vague
ce désintérêt est un mystère chronique
de la myopie industriels et sanitaires
européennes et françaises
vale neva belle biotech nantaise avait
tout pour être la première à proposer un
vaccin français aux européens c'est fait
mais pour les grands bretons qui ont
quitté l'union européenne
certainement parmi les plus gros
scandale de cette crise sevré vaccin
français classique à virus atténué parmi
les moins risqués du marché n'est pas
disponible en france
c'est une honte après les difficultés
rencontrées par sanofi et l'institut
pasteur
les espoirs de voir se développer un
vaccin made in france s'envole donc pour
l'instant en tout cas avec valve n'est
pas là sanofi pasteur il ya aussi le
fait que nous n'ayons pas été rendez au
rendez-vous de la course au vaccin a mal
vécu
on peut dire ça vienne de loin tout ça
ça vient de loin mais douce tas de
bruxelles l'a fait revel neva dans cette
crise sanitaire c'est le coup de trop
peut-être même le coup de grâce